last week the Trump administration put
out its budget and it calls for cutting
a grant that pays for programs like
meals on wheels yeah at the same time
Trump wants to hike military spending by
fifty four billion dollars yeah
and get this he wants to cut meals on
wheels for the elderly and increase
military spending Andy it's like a
terrible idea isn't it well it is unless
unless what unless you make meals on
wheels a military program with Trump
proposing cutbacks to federal assistance
programs turning Meals on Wheels over to
the Pentagon just makes sense our troops
get the chance to hone their combat
readiness by practicing real-world
battle skills in a non-lethal
environment and by web anice in our
generosity our older citizens get their
food delivered right to their homes
faster and more efficiently than
civilian volunteers ever could
even if you're shooting a delicious
snack at people I don't think they'd be
delighted in that we see that again
those guys in slow mode I just they look
way too happy sexual ecstasy
[Laughter]
you